$42 million
in distributions, a $46.2 million exit,
$106 million in a weekend. Most people
hear those numbers and think, "Oh,
that's probably when he felt the
richest." That's actually not the truth.
The moment that I felt the wealthiest in
my entire life was when I had $100,000
in my bank account. That was the first
big unlock for me as a person. And the
reason is before that, I was sleeping on
a gym floor and doing math on whether I
could afford groceries, right? And once
I had $100,000, that was when I stopped
having to worry about tomorrow, right?
About paying rent, about paying dues,
about paying my cell phone bill, or
paying my car insurance. You can't think
about your long-term vision if you're
trying to pay rent, right? That's just
real. And so, in this video, I want to
give you a six-step roadmap, as clear as
humanly possible, to making and banking
your first $100,000. If you're a big
baller business owner, then you can skip
this one. But if you don't have that
yet, then this is just a pure give on my
part of trying to help you get there.
The first step is that we have to cut
all costs, so that we can take more
risk. When I say all costs, I mean all
costs. That means you don't eat out
anymore for anything. And if you're
hungry, you deal with it. And if it's
not from a discount grocery store, you
don't buy it.
Clothing?
Like,
what you have right now on your back is
everything you need for the next 2
years, period. No exceptions. Just keep
reusing it. Trade or go to Goodwill. You
go to work, you go home, and home is
ideally with your family, or worst case,
with another family also trying to make
it and save. And it's got to be as cheap
as you possibly can. And I say this as
somebody who lived through this. When I
was beginning my journey, I was
splitting a bedroom in a six-bedroom
house with one guy, just in that
bedroom. As in, like, every night we'd
stare at each other, and I'd be like,
"Good night, John." And he'd be like,
"Good night, Alex." And I'd blow out my
candle.
>> [laughter]
>> Everything about that was true, minus
the candle. And pro tip, if you sleep
with a fan on your face, it you can't
hear anything. So, you know,
if you have to deal with it, that's one
way to do it. But, I had roommates that
I I was paying like three or four
hundred dollars a month for a very long
time while I was beginning my business
and started actually make real money,
and I still stayed there. Now, the next
thing is going to be your car. So, if
you're thinking about expenses, ideally
a paid-off clunker is the best way to
go. If you can't, you want it to be as
cheap as humanly possible, but ideally
just pay off your car so you don't have
to think about it again. All right, so
that covers your food, your car, your
shelter. And the reason that this is so
important for us to basically stack up
this cash flow because you're working
and making money, but right now you're
probably spending all of it. So, it's
like we need to make this we need to
decrease it from the downside so we have
this cash flow, this fluff that we can
start spending and reinvesting in
getting more skills, which I'll talk
about in a second. All right, real
quick, if you're on this path to your
first 100K, I want to make it faster and
easier for you. So, this uh these books
I had 3.6 million of these books that
were donated by other entrepreneurs.
These books I'm personally donating. And
so, if you are on the path, you can get
all three of these books for the like
nothing, basically. Uh for just covering
the shipping. So, I think it's 16 or 17
bucks all in for all three hardback
shipped to you, plus a 30-day trial of
School so you actually use the stuff and
have the tools to apply it in. All
right, so it's like it's the best thing
we call the business backpack. It's
literally everything you need to get
started uh online. I'm not promising
you're going to be a zillionaire. I'm
not promising you're going to make
$100,000. I'm just saying it's a great
great way to start, and it's the best
it's one of the most valuable things I
can possibly give you. And again,
special thank you to all the
entrepreneurs who donated the books cuz
we're doing our best to give them out.
Now, we have to cut all of our time
costs. Step two is save time. And so, if
you work a nine-to-five job, this is
kind of just the reality of it. Your
nine-to-five job is not killing your
dreams. All right, so just stop
subscribing to that. You're wasting the
two four-hour chunks of the day that you
do have available to you, which is your
five to nine in the morning and your
five to nine at night. So, what you want
to be doing is instead of just like
mindlessly doom scrolling through life,
right? Instead, you're like, I have 4
hours before I have to go to work,
right? Now, if you work remotely, even
better cuz you can be more efficient
with it. If you're not remote, then it
might be 3 and 1/2 hours, or you just
wake up earlier. And I also say this to
someone who did this, right? The reason
that this whole like I wake up early in
the morning became a thing for me was
because that was the only time I could
get ahead. And so, I I very much believe
in Kobe Bryant's perspective on this.
So, it's like if everyone else is is,
you know, going to practice, he's like,
well, if I do two extra practices a day,
I'm going to move forward three times
faster. And so, one is we got our money
back. Two, we got our time back. Now
that we have our time back, we need to
minimize the distractions in that time
period because focus is achieved not
through addition, but subtraction. When
you remove everything else that doesn't
matter, s- focus is what's left. Now, if
you happen to be just If you're on your
path right now, so like let's say that
you have your you're not at job, so you
you started a business, but it's not
making as much as you want, and you
don't have the 100k savings. Let me just
give you the simplest formula that I had
this happen like the 2.0 version, which
is a 4-4-4 split. So, if you're at 9 to
5, then you got 5 to 9 and 5 to 9. If
you don't have a a 9 to 5 during the day
that you got to go to, then I like to do
4 hours of promotion. First thing I do
when I get up is let people know about
my stuff because if nobody knows about
your stuff, they can't give you money.
The second 4-hour chunk is delivery. So,
you give the people that give you money
what you promised them. The third 4-hour
chunk is building. So, this is building
the future. Figure out what to do next
and how to do it. This is
a combination of two things. It's going
to be the curation of opportunities.
Like, what are all the things that are
out there? I have to see them, find
them, and then the second is the
prioritization of those. Okay, there's
10 things I could do. This one thing is
going to get me the highest return. This
is what I'm going to prioritize my time
and money towards.
So, big picture, you promote, you
deliver, and you build.
That's what you do with your time. Now,
regardless of what job or business you
have, if you want to save time, you need
to understand this concept, which is
understanding whether you are a maker or
a manager. A maker is when you're in the
build mode. This is when you're
completely locked in, you're like, "No
distractions. I have to go learn stuff.
I have to go write copy. I have to go
edit videos. I have to go make content.
I have to go build this template that
I'm going to sell to my customers."
Whatever. Manager is when you're
interacting with other people. Now, that
could be client calls, that could be
team calls, that could be vendor calls,
any kind of conversations that you have
to have, Slack messages, whatever. The
thing is is that managers, their
perfectly productive day is no blank
time, right? It's 5-minute chunks and
you're just trying to have as many
touchpoints and decisions as possible.
A maker, a perfectly productive day is a
completely empty calendar. So, I don't
know if you're anything like me, when I
look at my calendar I truly have nothing
on it, I feel one, this immense sense of
relief and two, this huge amount of
energy of possibility. Like, what big
thing can I get done today? And that's
when I really move the ball forward. And
I'm telling you like the the life hack
of all hacks, a single habit that has
changed my output, was having my first
four to six hours of my day to myself.
So, when you're in that maker manager
decision mode, I like to block at the
micro level my day is maker time,
manager time, and then keep them
separated because the biggest killer of
productivity is task switching, right?
So, if you're trying to make and then
you're slacking and then you're making
and then you're texting, you're you're
screwed, right? So, instead, you just
have to put the blinders on your maker
period and then when you're in the
manager period it's like, go for it.
Just be distracted and know that that's
like the rest of your day is screwed.
And I accept that. Like, for me, Mondays
are my day that I'm a manager and the
rest of the week I try to do my absolute
best to be a maker. Now that we have the
money saved up and we're still we got
some cash, so we drove down our living
expenses, we drove down our time
expenses so we have free time, and we're
organizing it well and we're focused and
productive during that time period, what
do we do with the time? Three, which is
research a skill that people already pay
money for. And this is a key part. What
you want to do, especially if you're
like, "I need to make more than I am
right now," go find what people are
already paying for, right? So, on a B2C
side, it just looks you look at all the
things that a business does, right? So,
a business gets advertised, so they make
content, they do outreach, there's the
funnel building process that's
associated with that. All of those
things, each of those
are skills that on their own, you could
go build yourself a million dollar plus
business off of. Just one of those. And
so, that's just on a B2B side as an
example. On the B2C side, here's a very
easy hack. Just print out your credit
card statement or your bank statement
and look at what you actually spend
money on. So, just think when you're
selling to consumers, I'm going to give
them time back that they otherwise
wouldn't have. And for business owners,
you're giving them money that they
otherwise wouldn't have. But don't get
overwhelmed with the zillion things that
you can that you can learn there. Pick
one. And so, I have a a a 111 rule,
which is you want to sell one product or
service to one avatar
on one channel until you make $1
million.
That's it. So, we saved our money, we
saved our time, and then we researched
the skill that people are already paying
for today. That leads us to number four.
Spend time learning. All right, so first
of all, it's important that you
understand what learning is if we're
going to say what it means. So, I say
this because a lot of people spend their
time trying to learn or sitting in front
of a computer or listening to podcast or
whatever, but it doesn't actually change
behavior, which ding ding ding, that is
the definition of learning, which is
same condition, new behavior. If you're
in the same condition, meaning you're in
the same bedroom, you're looking at the
same computer, and what you're doing
every day is not changing, you are not
learning.
So, use that as a simple litmus test
for understanding whether the content
that you were consuming
is valuable. If you cannot translate it
or the person who's teaching you,
whoever it is, me or anyone, into what
do I do now? So, there's this big thing
Malcolm Gladwell talked about 10,000
hours is this common theme, which is
it's not 10,000 hours, but 10,000
iterations. And the reason I like that
framing is because it assumes that you
will fail, and it assumes that you will
get better
as you learn, right? It is that 10,000
iterations is a proxy for feedback
loops, which means that if you do
something and you get no feedback, it's
virtually impossible to learn. So, when
we were doing stuff in the real world, a
lot of times real world will give you
feedback loop. You post this content,
nothing happens. That is still feedback.
It's that it sucked, right? But you can
still get better. The fastest way to
learn skills is to find somebody who's
really good and hire them one-on-one.
Fastest way to learn skills. I still did
this in my early days, even when I
barely could afford it. So, when I say I
learn with the first-party data, I give
you a handful of examples, but this is a
do this instruction list. So, number
one, you have to do a lot of volume in
order to learn, right? I can't just have
one sales call recording. I can't just
one comment that I try and learn from. I
have to have lots of comments that I
have to aggregate. I got to put them
together.
Number two is that I analyze the top
10%. So, what are the top 10% of sales
calls? What are the top 10% of content?
What are the the top 10, you know,
customer service resolution,
uh you know, person? What are What are
What are these top 10% outcomes? What do
they have in common that the other 90%
don't have? And you can apply this to
any subject matter that you're trying to
learn. So, that is step three. You
analyze the difference. Step four is you
figure out the most important details
like the eyes, like the feet, like the
whatever. And this is This is where a
lot of people struggle is that they they
don't know which part is important. And
that's part of learning is that you're
like, "There's six differences.
I don't know which one was the reason."
So, you start trying them one at a time.
It just is what it is. And then the
final step is avoid the mistakes that
the 90% is making uh that are keeping
them at the bottom and do more of the
stuff the top 10% and you just continue
to do another 100 repetitions, look at
the top 10, try and make the next 100
look like those 10, and do it over and
over again and again until people are
like, "Man, you're so good at this. You
must be a natural." And that is
fundamentally how you learn any skill.
We saved our money so we could get
aggressive. We saved our time so we'd
have time to to actually do the work. We
researched which skills to learn. Then,
we spent our time actually learning, and
we went walked through exactly what
those 10,000 iterations look like. So,
what do we do now? Step five is you
spend the money in the right places. So,
I think of this in three bigger buckets.
You've got tools, you've got
implementation help, and then you've got
trial attempts. So, think about that as
like, where am I going to spend this
time and money? Cuz you actually have to
do this in order to get out. Like, if
you're if you're just like, "Okay, I'm
saving my time, saving money." You're
not going to get to 100k, right? Like,
you have to do stuff, too. So, for
tools, that might mean that you might
buy a software tool, right? That might
mean like a CRM or a landing page thing
or school is nine bucks a month, right?
Like, chill. All right. Um to get
started, right? Because for you to like
the alternative is you could try rebuild
the entire thing. Yeah, or you could
just like go to grab a tool that's
already there. Save yourself some time.
So, that's what kind of tools looks
like. Implementation, this is where you
can buy courses, you can buy uh
communities on school if you're looking
at to learn anything. You can uh get
tutoring, which I'm a huge advocate of,
and for some reason this is like falling
out of vogue. Um but if you can get
someone to just give you one-on-one
help, my god, it's so valuable. Um the
next is trial attempts. So, that means
like, "Okay, I want to start running
ads." Okay, great. Well, you got to
spend money on ads. Or like, "Hey, um I
want to start, you know, making
content." You're going to have to spend
money on maybe some of the editing
software that goes with that. Like, of
course, there are free things and be as
cheap as possible, but accept that some
of these things are kind of minor
investments that will give you huge
leverage on your time. So, the last step
and the whole point of all this is to
just increase your active income. People
look at the billionaires, they're like,
"Oh, they live on passive income." What
people miss is that most billionaires
who are self-made made their money from
making money. Meaning, they had active
income. They had monster active income
that they could deploy. Like, you get
rewarded for the risk you take on. You
cannot take any risk on if you have no
time and no money.
So, you need to go take go find that
risk, create something that you can put
at risk so that you can get rewarded for
it. And we do that through increasing
our skill sets and our active income.
And so, you're like, "Okay, well, those
are the five steps. So, what's the last
step?" Number six,
do not increase your lifestyle. All
right? I I know guys who are making
$40,000 a month and made it for years.
Great sales guys and spent every single
dollar. I've got multiple friends who
didn't start saving money until they're
40s. And they were like, "Oh my god, I
can't believe I I just like lived that
way." Right? You want to be rich, not
look rich. Right? This is about 100k in
the bank, not 100k in revenue.
Everything minus food and shelter is
your profit. I say this is once things
started working out for my gym, my first
gym, I was making about $20,000 a month
in income, personal. I was still
splitting the room, paying $400 a month
in rent. Because I was like, "Well,
dude, I need to say like my goal was not
to stop at $20,000 a month." I was like,
"I want to go big. And I'm going to need
all this cash to open a new location, to
learn more stuff, to attend more
conferences, all of this stuff cuz I
wanted to learn." And so, basically the
day that you stop spending money on
learning is the day you decide that you
do not want to make more. And so,
zooming all the way out, the six steps
to getting your first $100,000,
you got to stop spending money so you
have money to spend on the right stuff.
You got to stop wasting time so that you
have time to invest in the right stuff.
What stuff do you invest in? Number
three is you have to research. You got
to pick. You got to look. And the best
way to look is not to risk it on
something that you don't know, but find
stuff people are already spending money
on. The fourth is now that we know the
thing that we're going to focus on,
we're going to eliminate all the other
distraction and we're going to spend all
our time learning. Number five, the
money that you do have, you want to
spend on tools,
implementation help, and attempts,
trying it and failing.
And then finally, once things actually
start working, you never get to the 100k
in a bank account just by increasing
your income. You also got to not let
your lifestyle take back over so you can
finally bank it. And the reason this is
so kind of near and dear to my heart is
that when I had the first 100k was the
first time that I mean I remember
looking at Leila and I was like, "We did
it." I said, "We could do nothing and
off for 3 and 1/2 years."
And it was crazy cuz like I think about
that now, right? Two people, $100,000 in
savings, 3 years. And I wasn't think
about it in terms of investments or
anything like that. I just knew that I
didn't have to worry about rent. I
didn't have to worry about food. And
that was when I was able to really start
thinking long-term. And so I want as
many people as possible to get that
point because many of you have bigger
dreams than that. But you can't get
there until you pass this checkpoint.
Like it's Maslow's hierarchy of needs.
Like until you're you're not thinking
about food and shelter, it's amazing to
want to change the world, but if you got
to pay rent tomorrow, you got to pay
rent tomorrow, right? And so this is the
plan to help you do that.